ah okay ich mache das auch okay
[Musik]
hallöchen leute und herzlich willkommen
zurück zu captain minecraft haben mit
komme und in der letzten folge haben wir
einfach zwei erfolge geschafft das davor
war er seine durststrecke und ich hab
dann einfach mal nachgeschaut hat mir
gedacht komm wir können ja eigentlich
braun sohn braucht es braut dingsbums
zeug hier alchemie teil ist ja nicht so
teuer dankeschön haben nämlich einfach
so eine dickflüssige krank gemacht dann
gegen die world bauarbeiter dann hat man
eine kiste hier gefunden und dann haben
wir einen fisch geangelt also com hat
ein geangelt hatte in einem brief an
und dann hatten wir die un fordert
wieder um den halben blog weiter und
jetzt haben wir die farben hier noch so
ein cooler gemacht und unser plan für
heute ist erstmal dass wir die kiste
oben schauen guck mal die rallye sind
auch schon weiter gewachsen
was können wir uns die bringen werden
weiß ich jetzt auch nicht dafür brauchen
wir eine schere um die abzubauen aber
wir wollten wir haben ja versprochen
dass wir in dieser folge in die kiste
oben schauen und da sind wir jetzt
gerade auf dem weg in ich hoffe nur dass
ich weiter auf die folter spannen oder
gehen wir direkt hoch ich hoffe nicht
dass uns dass wir von einem gas begrüßt
werden
also ja ich auch nicht ich habe nur zwei
pfeile dabei vielleicht hast du ja noch
welche in der kiste und sind noch 18
oder egal also frei haben wir auf jeden
fall noch aber wenn wir schon hier oben
sind naja ich habe jetzt auch nur ob sie
will hat mit womit ich mich wehren
können und nicht nur wegen ihr mal ein
erfolg war immer da ist ein element weil
man einfach mal zusammen den enthüllten
und klettere als das gerät als das geld
komme ja aber von hier unten gilt das
noch nicht denn ich hätte einfach weiter
hoch das ist gut ich hatte einfach die
leiter weiter hoch die geht ja noch
weiter hoch und da ist ja ich nicht die
truhe
ich hole mal eben noch ein paar pfeile
das wäre perfekt beeil dich aber ja ich
weiß ich kann auch nicht schneller
leiter leiter hochklettern als es geht
ich glaube ich weiß ich bin jetzt auch
sprint hat hier oben ich habe keinen
essen mitgenommen er der nahrung habe
ich aber 36 münchen gebraten
wer dann gibt mir bitte was man sieht
auf jeden fall das skelett von hier wo
ich stehe
damit kann das lokale töten ich schaue
nicht auf die höhe
ok die muss dann aber noch weiter nach
oben genannten die nimm dir am besten
steine mit welcher hast ja ich hab doch
was zu essen
ich muss erst mal schauen wo jetzt hier
stadion so hier wo ich christine ja da
du willst wahrscheinlich gleich 133 ist
die höhe
das heißt rechne mal aus 933 183
schließt soll ich hier die irgendwie die
blöcke abbauen dass du dadurch schießen
kann es oder so kannst du machen
vielleicht jetzt besser achtung jetzt
kann ich habe ich bin gerade jetzt auf
der richtigen höhe so stark nevado ich
glaube ich erkenne das gesetz das nun
ändern wenn auch ne ja der ist was glad
steht so vor dem ende von mir aus
gesehen
apple genug pfeile
ja du hast getroffen einmal ja ist tot
ich habe alles gemacht wie es eigentlich
sein sollte
[Musik]
oder war das ist das einfach so töten
skelett mit einem pfeil aus einer
entfernung von mehr als 50 blog aber ich
war eigentlich um 0,9 was darüber auch
eine der etwa ein blog höher gehen
müssen oder es kann ja auch sein dass
das so ist wie mit der lore dass man das
so einen einem stück machen muss also
dass man das skelett irgendwie aus 50
glocken so eine weite weiße mit einem
pfeil tod eines gerät mit einem pfeil
steht da ja ich habe zwei pfeile
gebraucht das heißt ich hätte nur noch
höher gehen müssen so naja kommt beginnt
mal eben erst mal eben den ändern und
töten war ja auch gut bevor du noch
drauf wird erstmal die ganzen hin und
danach öffnen wir dann die truhe
ich habe angst dass der inder man
wiederkommen hier ist noch nahrung für
dich hinter dir ja ich habe etwas so und
ist die truhe da müssen wir irgendwie
hatte ich springe auch schon hin und
wartet immer noch die hühnchen so warten
wir müssen irgendwie von hier hinten und
da hat es mich drauf springen
alter wie soll ich da nein kommen ja
eigentlich war da mal ein baum oder
warum ist da nicht mehr weil ein baum
eine treppe ich mache das vernünftig
deutsche wertarbeit sagen ja so packe
ich wollte auf die kiste draufstehen
hab's nicht geschafft ich möchte die
öffnen juju ich mach das auch okay ein
verzaubertes buch gestoppt haben
naja wenn wir jetzt halt gleich haben
nie und wenn wir an bord hätten also für
notfall kommen damit dieses schon gold
nugget auch wieder damit klar einen
kollegen aber frauen liegt an fichten
sitzen drinnen der merzig und leder
wofür braucht man leder für bücher
eventuell leder kann man ja für bücher
nehmen
ja genau wenn man keine kuh er hat
eigentlich wahrscheinlich ja wir haben
ja keine
wir haben hier nur eine skitour am
besten mal wir runter ich probiere es
noch mal mit dem skelett das ist so
schön dass wir bei also wasser verlangen
da kanns einfach unterschiedlich gut
gemacht
eigenlob warte jetzt bringe ich noch
daran falls das irgendwie das freut mich
gar nicht ja cool ich habe da keine
einseitig stehe ich gehe auf der leiter
ich bin einfach noch mal runter biologie
oder vielleicht sollten wir ein kleines
loch in diesem obwohl ich weiß nicht
vielleicht sollten wir auf diesen dingen
auffangbecken machen ja dass das können
wir nicht machen so ach ja ich wollte
erstmal die ganzen wertvollen packen
alle sachen die natur waren diese
hintere acht tagen auch items von dir
danke schön zu hören
so also da kommt alles wertvolle rein
das kommt rein
ja das leder warte das bin ich aus der
truhe ausgepackt heran
das noch nicht gewachsen ja das ist ja
doof und dem skelett jetzt gewesen war
durch hits wie hoch jetzt dürft ihr wir
null stimmen hoffen aber hast du die
knochen von dem skelett warum und die
daten dann wollen wir dass kein knochen
ja ja dann gebt mir mal bitte dann kann
ich mich vielleicht mal den fichten
setzlingen nur wofür ist dass wir
irgendwie was versteckt ist leicht vom
gros ob als chief mentor ich zurück mit
drei knochenmehl auf den setzlingen der
wechsel war nicht der blink dreimal und
wächst nicht ging ja egal wie kriegen
wir noch arbeiten so warte jetzt nochmal
an den ende seid weil ich da rein
denn auxerre player kommt in die essens
kiste ja das ist doof und dem mit dem
hotel das einfach steht mehr als 72 york
oben ja und das ist wirklich doof weil
da halt jetzt nur noch privatmann noch
ein bisschen was zu essen da rein das ei
kommt mal dahin
diese ganzen hühnchen wo mein gott und
die wolke da oben auch manchmal diese
ganzen das sind alles kleine münchen
irgendwie oder sind das große alter da
sind ja viel zu viele hühner oh mein
gott als ich einmal diesen hühnern in
das loch gegangen 36 aber nicht alter
ich glaube ich töte einfach alle hühner
die da drin sitzen wir haben eh genug
über kommt von oben geflogen
das hühnerei
overhage schafft wenn du noch mal sand
brauchst kommt auch von erhoben geflogen
bei uns auf dem dach glaube ich haltern
erdrutschen das schiff das hühnchen
unter euch die krise hier mit ich
brauche diesen gang zu den bruchweg an
dass sie die mal schön aus ich glaube
nach der karte hier können wir beide
keine hühnchen mehr sehen aha haben wir
schon wir genug mittel ist von oben
geflogen kommen man man man etr guck mal
lachen wieder
irgendwie sind so viel erhöhen ich finde
die flucht tötete steht wieder was von
meinen augen gut so ich jetzt erstmal
noch die menschen hier an soll du kommst
noch mit hallo ich kenne die schweiz
schickt ihr beide erstmal schön kommt
schon wieder drei teams darunter
geschossen oder league ist hier gerade
recht die ganze leiter hinunter leiter
von roche flogen
ja okay wir brauchen mehr holz für die
noch für die genau weiß was meine für
die farm
ok also wenn du irgendwie wie nur irgend
wie heute ist glaube ich oben noch
welche liegen ich bin gerade gestorben
ist so gut ist sich gerade wirklich kein
hallo ich sagen hey zwar keine kinder
gemacht
hallo peter ich mal die müsse auch in
dem land stehen schubsen
die gucken sich nur an mehr machen die
nicht doch jetzt haben sie ein kind die
steht so zwei blöcke auseinander und auf
einen reporter so ein kleines baby
büchern filmen wir kommen noch hühner
getötet habe aber da fallen mir so viel
essen aber ich habe so viele übrig
gelassen dass wir noch weiter vermehren
können okay wir haben ja einer textilien
fleisch ich habe gedacht dass wir auch
vegetarische umsteigen deswegen die
ganze karotten angepflanzt aber
irgendwie hat sich das nicht tue ich mir
über quoten braucht man weiterhin für
die schweine beispiel auch kaum welche
das wäre so mal werden und dadurch ihre
schweinefleisch also sind wir trotzdem
noch keine vegetarier
das stimmt wir haben so viel essen das
ist ja so krass oh mein gott das kann ja
mächtig sein
ich bin schon so oft gestorben das auch
so krasse so krass ich warte schon die
ganze zeit dass unsere unser zucker
weiter wächst ich habe wieder recht
bekommen sie dann jetzt ja auch mal was
geht ab bei dir was machst du da
eigentlich wieder
ich musste mein tipp ist wieder der alte
bahnsteig bin aber ja kommen habe ich
immer noch nicht
ich glaub ich geh jetzt mal unten erhöhe
man mal ganz gut ich schauen was da
abgeht
vielleicht kriegt ja auch noch immer ein
bisschen leise und du meinst es da genug
platz gemacht um junge da unten sitzt
auch schon in münchen
da sitzt ein hühnchen bei uns in der
höhle für bleibt gemacht für die bäume
vielleicht oder hat einen ich habe ich
nicht ich habe auf keinen fall da unten
genug platz da war zwar eine stelle wo
man die eventuell an pflanzen könnte
aber ich glaube die stelle hätte auch
nicht gereicht
wir sind überall slime sonst glätte und
zwei skelette aber die kanzel nicht aus
50 blöcken entfernung töten weil die
halt hier und in der höhle sind
das gleiche sogar zwei kriege ich meine
das geht auch irgendwann mal auf
jetzt muss ich auch mal was fressen
alter sind hier viele motto kommen dann
alle er
wir haben die gänge wie hoffnung macht
stimmt ja egal dann ist hier unten halt
immer wenn man wenn man erfahrung
aufweisen wenn man erfahrung will kann
man einfach eine höhle hier unten gehen
zehn millionen mops ich habe drei eisen
oder die wie eine rüstung wir müssen uns
echt meine vernünftiges zu machen und
dann nicht so dumm sterben dass wir
alles verlieren bestimmt wie durchfall
januar sowie könnte man überhaupt
durchfall sterben stimmt wie kann man
sich halt schaden durch stellen ob man
das ist doch ungerecht unser zucker
rohren er ist noch keinen einzigen meter
gewachsen teilte das recht traurig ich
gehe noch ein stück nach unten
ich weiß auch wie werden dass eine
zuckerrohr hinter der abgrenzung kommen
könnten durch den körper weil die
explosion also ich hatte ja selber
basteln dann ist doch alles weg jetzt
stimmt auch nicht dass prioritäten
setzen ja bald kommt ja hast du schon
gehört hast du die explosion gehört hier
hab ich glaube ja da waren kripo um eine
spitzhacke ja da war und meine
spitzhacke ist kaputt aber ich bin nicht
gestorben und ich will wir müssen das
hier alles mal schöner bauen
das mache ich in deiner folge dann passt
es gar nix und ja auch teil mit krieg
bekämpfen
ich gehe jetzt mal in den end raum komm
doch mit du hast ja auch keine aufnahme
ja nicht einmal wegen drohender das
machen wir dann in der nächsten folge
weil meine folge ist auch schon wieder
zu ende
ich packe jetzt noch ganz schnell die
wertvollen sachen rein so dieses eisen
oder so was ich halt gefunden haben ist
hier und gold und alles und du findest
ist einfach nicht ja ich bin stark und
ich hab übrigens 15 knochen mir geholt
in meinem
peter loosen kampf mit den skeletten
nice wenig was sag ich dir noch daran
sich die samen noch daran
sie haben soll die knochen mehr jetzt
eben für was nutzen das passt mal auf
dass du in zukunft nicht über das feld
stolperte und sind immer so ein paar
dinge halt erwarte ich benutze das jetzt
für diesen aber guck mal ich habe so
eine aktion gerade wieder ich bin hier
gerade wir kurz vor diesem end raum
hier sind geräusche die habe ich noch
nie gehört in minecraft ein gewinner
hölle ist dass sie gerade vor den
geräuschen als ob den castor so wäre wir
haben jetzt unseren pflichten teilen
übrigens na also ich fälle denen jetzt
mal eben ganz kurz ich weiß nicht ob das
etwas bringt
oder kommt schon wenn es ja nix und eine
spitzhacke es kaputt nicht bauen mit
cobblestone hoch ja gut es folgen egal
ich würde sagen wenn es euch gefallen
hat dann lasst auf jeden fall eine
bewertung da die nächste folge könnt ihr
beim bhd morgen begutachten und dann
werden wir unten in das and poor talraum
gehen und werden mal schauen ob wir da
unten irgendwie ins entkommen und das
nächste tief mit anlocken können und
dann würde ich sagen auf jeden fall